I was I was wondering how many people
would find it interesting but I was told
on Friday night that there's probably a
spurious correlation between people to
enjoy pythons and data science and
clearly enjoy mobile games so it's a
pretty good pretty good thing there and
so I'm Andrew Karsen on a date scientist
at natural motion I actually need all
the analytics data science for one of
our games done at Titans and but this is
kind of out these are the kind of games
that we've got so don't ins is kind of a
mid core game where you kind of battle
but battles like a social battling game
so you're building a city upgrading your
troops upgrading these Titans and
battling each other and trying to
basically just win the game so this r2
is a more of a racing game so you're
doing a similar thing but you're
upgrading your cars and then you're
racing against your friends and things
like that we have the CSR franchise
which obviously sort have been built on
and then we have some other smaller
games that kind of we start out with I
would implore you all to download clumsy
ninja because fun really fun and so I'm
going to talk to you about how we deal
with cheaters specifically with Don
times but actually this this whole
concept has happened across dollar times
and CSR - and they are obviously in
social games a huge huge issue because
it's not just that they are cheating us
they're actually cheating the other
players that are playing the game first
one I just go through quickly the
free-to-play model I think everyone
understands most mobile games now in
this free-to-play model which is great
because we can get our games into the
hands of as many people as possible who
have a good enough to advice to play
them but it comes with a problem so does
anybody understand what this percentage
might be yeah
well not necessarily Wales but this is
actually just the percentage of people
who convert in free-to-play games and so
it's I mean amazingly we hope that we
have a huge amount of his user base
playing but a very small amount of
people that actually give us revenue as
a business we still you know it's to
knee to make money and actually that
only comes from about 2% of our players
so if we're thinking about detecting
cheated in that game it's a real
problematic thing because if we're
thinking about them as out
in the data that we're looking at
actually 100% of our revenue is also
coming from outliers so it's them it
comes to you know it's a problem that we
have so I'm gonna quickly talk through
just quickly how what you would cheat in
a game this is donna titans this is my
daughter titans on my mobile i'm crash
kid only level 4 started on my start on
a new mobile recently and so a lot lot
of games of them a lot of games have
currencies in the game so obviously
that's a really really obvious area that
you had hype the game give yourself more
currency and to do things buy things in
the game things like that potentially
gems which is kind of a hard currency
that's where you skip waste come from
like skipping through the game comes
from and basically buying some of the
bigger items and this is where kind of
our IPS are attached
we have vp which is social currency and
so what you use that for is oh any of
you battle somebody you get more vp you
rise at the ranks get rewards and things
like that and then there's loads of
other things like your actual general
player profile which gives you extra
wasn't another so i just want to show
you this for a second because here this
is the kind of social map in our game
and we've got carlos 8 9 or 5 here now
is he a cheater as a player I don't see
him as a cheater he looks very similar
to me he's got a few more lands but it
looks very similar to me now he could be
cheating but Ness this isn't necessarily
the problem like actually don't mind if
I really care if he is if it has ways of
nominally cheating in our game because
it's not really affecting me but I'm not
sick perceiving him to have a hair kind
of to be better than me because of it
because of that I'm saying hey how you
know how is he upgrading himself so
quickly uh-oh and when he's obviously a
cheater you know and I'm going to as a
player not like the game because of it
and so what we're trying to do is find
it we don't have to care about all of
this cheats in the game we actually just
wanna care about the player facing ones
the ones that are really going to affect
other players and in the game so just
gonna quickly run through I'm from an
engineering level how people cheat so
these games are always online so they're
always talking to the game server every
transaction you do every kind of buttons
like you do with we're talking to the
game server
so from a client side there's the
obviously obvious tax you can actually
download hacked builds off the off
online this is not one of our games I'm
not going to show you show you the apk
for our own games this one's for clash
Royale please don't also don't download
that one either
and then so that these already have like
it's basically the easiest way they're
pre companies so like you'll have loads
of gems to play you might even just
start at a higher level and you know
it's effectively you haven't spent any
money and you can just rule again these
are actually generally quite heated a to
em to stop there's also these assistant
applications so you could have a
completely fine gaming on your mobile
and use an assistant application to just
change values in our metadata and this
is this is a harder problem because
actually people generally do it in
smaller smaller increments like just
when they need it they'll change the
value and and so you may even you know
from looking through the data you may
look quite normal but actually you're
kind of just you're edging you're just
edging there with your cheatin there's
also like Network edits which is really
really tough so your client can be
completely fine and the transaction is
sent to the server is then just captured
and you can then edit that so you don't
even need to be online at this point
people can actually just capture these
them capturing these kind of
transactions and then just send them to
the server obviously the survey is
robust enough to understand most of them
but this is an arms race like every time
we find every time we find a way to stop
something some clever clogs finds a new
way to do it so it's a constant arms
race and this is why rather than dealing
with from an engineering point of view
which we do we should also need to
double down on kind of catching users
within game so this is where it comes
from an outlier detection problem so as
the transactions come in the easiest
thing to do which is so a lot of the
ways that we deal with cheaters is just
deal it from a transaction level so this
transaction has changed our currency by
X amount and you know whether that was
an outlier or not but as I've said like
a lot of the time it's just scope creep
it's like creeping creeping creeping
cheating so actually what we need to do
is aggregate the user level data to kind
of understand overtime
how big a difference if they made that
Network than we were expecting them to
do so I'm going to walk through some
kind of different ways that we've dealt
with you know cheating as an outlier
detection problem start from the
simplest approach and really just move
forward with that so obviously you have
got single variate solutions and so if
you look here we've kind of got battle
win ratios here or play a player
progression on your first day and you
this is in in terms of the mathematics
is something called kurtosis which is
really simple thinking it's just really
the amount of tail that you have on your
distribution you need to assume that
high kurtosis means that this variable
has a lot of outliers compared to your
normally distributed data and so we can
kind of use that to understand what
variables perceive as outliers versus
versus not so you can see here for
player progression there's a huge long
tail here so it's very easy to expect
that you know these are these are huge
outliers here and and it's not possible
to get to some of these levels on your
first day so we know for a straight away
that these people are cheating and so
it's a really really simple method and
in fact actually we don't necessarily
need to do some deep level data science
here we can just put in theoretical
maximums and say you can't you know it's
not possible for you to get here whereas
actually with the battlin ratios it's a
bit harder like you could you could be
winning a hell of a lot of battles
compared to what you should be doing but
but there's more nuances and more issues
there so if we look at from a
multivariate solution you can obviously
see that the battle win ratios may
affect to be affected by the troops that
you take into the game so obviously
that's quite correlated but they're
still going to be out lies there so
we've created in a single variable
create a distance metric from a kind of
averaging I mean so how do we do that in
the multivariate sense it's not just a
kind of Euclidean distance so what we
want to kind of want to do is create
that ellipsoid around so that we can
kind of understand that this is an
outlier just as this is an outlier even
though for example they are actually
very very different in terms of distance
from the average point of our data what
we use is the maillot notice distance
and what this is doing is is really just
creating a similar distance metric
but taking into account the variance of
each of the M variables the easiest way
to think about that is if we on the
two-dimensional space if we actually
just took a simple principle component
so in fact actually we've just scaled
down our variance not necessarily the
fact that they're non correlated that
doesn't really matter here but and the
fact that we scale down our variance
means that it's now just a simple kind
of nuclear lien distance around that
space so that projection now if you
think about the malarious distance it's
basically just a Euclidean distance in
the kind of projection a scale invariant
projection cool so yeah so K back to the
problem is are these cheaters I mean
we've got people who who are winning a
lot of battles but they've also got a
high troop score maybe the troop score
is the problem that's the thing but
you've actually also got outliers here
that are just people who are really bad
AI they're not very good at the King so
this is the thing like whenever we do as
we going through this it's like outliers
doesn't equal cheaters at all it's
actually just so we need to be really
really careful on on what we're actually
detecting as an outlier and what we're
actually pushing through as a potential
cheater in the game there's also a
notion on this so for it
this outlier is kind of around around
completely around the distribution so
even if we calculated the like the
ellipsoid the mean is probably even if
we take some of those outliers out that
mean is probably going to be in a
similar place so we can kind of properly
understand that a little not necessarily
having to worry about the outliers this
is a really really actually just nicked
it straight from the scikit-learn
website but only because it was just it
is the simplest approach simplest kind
of graphical representation of the
importance of kind of understanding a
robust measurement of that kind of
ellipsoid around your distributions so
if you took actually an ellipsoid and
included those outliers it's going to be
very very highly skewed so what you need
to do is kind of understand what the
ellipsoid might look like through kind
of
samples of your data such that you're
trying to take out those outliers and
try and get a good graphical
representation so the mean of this
ellipsoid is not necessarily the mean of
your data it's actually it's actually
the mean of kind of your non out Lyday
to your inliers
you can use two approaches for that
there's a minimum covariance determine
which is actually inside Caitlin there's
also a minimum volume ellipsoid which is
a slightly more robust mechanism but
effectively the minimum covariance term
is a kind of direct calculation a
minimum volume ellipsoid is is an
iterative method where actually what we
going to do is just sample smaller sets
of our data calculate an ellipsoid that
covers a certain amount of of our data
points and then just take the smallest
one - the one with the least outliers in
it that's the kind of a sort of
calculation of what what I kind of mean
and the very covariance of our data
could be so this so just skipping back
this works well for normal uni-modal
data but as you get to higher dimensions
this is not necessarily what you're
going to see like even and so you need
to kind of abstract this and think about
a different way of doing it so rather
than a distance measure I'm going to
kind of show you an error measure and
what we're going to do is use neural
nets so I'm guessing you've probably
seen picture like this about 10 times
this weekend but what's them so what
we're going to do is actually just
create a really really simple neural net
which is going to take our input vector
of our data of our users and we're going
to learn the kind of structure of this
data and output and try and basically
replicate that data from a lower
dimension similar to what you'd see is
maybe an autoencoder
the work the reason this is good for
outliers is actually as it learns the
structure of the data any variable that
any any kind of sample that we put into
the neuron there that doesn't actually
fit that structure is going to it
compute it's going to be really really
bad at predicting that data so in fact
actually what we can do is create an
outlier factor or an outlier score
similar to the distance metric but
actually it's just an error metric
you know we've built on your net to
understand the structure of our data but
the as you put a sample through in it
and it's never seen before it's not
going to be able to predict it and
therefore it is an outlier based on kind
of what no data normally looks like so
it's reasonable to assume that and the
way the way that this works is actually
is you want to represent your data in a
lower dimension so you don't want to
actually 100% replicate your data you
just want to kind of estimator it's
reasonable to assume that in your nets I
mean you can you can optimize in your
very very well to the point where even
if you take a sample of your data and
maybe it has one or two of your outliers
in it even if it has a couple of samples
it's probably going to try and
understand you know if there's a good
chance it may understand the structure
of that data and so actually you may
find might find two outliers in your
data not having a huge outlier factor so
what we kind of do with this replicate
in your net is there's from the paper
directly there's a activation function
which effectively just creates a step
function so rather than this middle
hidden layer having a fully continuous
output it could take any value we're
actually only going to give it a certain
set of values so effectively just
clustering our data down into these into
this hidden layer so for example here
we've got three inputs and effectively
what we're saying bit of three
continuous variables but we're
effectively going to try and represent
that as just two neurons four steps
eight piece of eight bits of data and
then I met is going to kind of try and
predict out that data again and there's
going to be a an outlier factor based on
kind of how badly we did so there's a
big problem of this in an implementation
standpoint this completely makes sense
for for out like prediction from a
theoretical standpoint but from a so
we're kind of actually implementing this
is really tough these step functions if
you're for example training you honor on
kind of gradient descent it's not
possible to move through this activation
function because the different
the M if you differentiate these values
they're all just zero on those kind of
flat planes so in practice what we
actually did is just which is actually
just kind of relax these conditions and
bring it back to a continuous variable
which is you're probably thinking what
like you just talked about how important
this is and you just thrown it away now
so but if it but it's an important thing
to just note because we can still use
this continuous distribution so you have
two likely continuous activation
function but given that we know the
problems with it it means that we just
make sure that when we're training it we
kind of have a very very early stopping
criteria and in practice in practice
like when we actually did this we
probably had a very very early stopping
criteria because we actually had a lot
of false positives in terms of what we
thought were outliers but it was M but
we found that this was probably the best
approach this wasn't definitely the best
approach and going back to this versus
the distributions is we were able to
feed it much more much different data
and you know kind of both bimodal data
or very very high skewed data and it
dealt with it and very very well so
that's kind of a whirl whirl whirl wind
that goes through em out lie detection
and so let's just touch on a few other
points of just kind of a whole process
so before we even put into the outlay
detection system like whatever model we
use how do we deal with variable
selection when we're talking about
outliers it's not it's not a simple cut
and dry process you do a classification
you're just going to kind of take the
mutual information it's like a very very
simple approach is just take the mutual
information of each variable and you
take your top X variables and run that
through your model or that topics just
being a high parameter to kind of
optimize but in out in kind of out lie
detection and particularly out lie
detection trying to find cheaters we
can't necessarily just take variables
that have a high a high difference
between their inliers and outliers so
this is one way you can do it you can
actually algorithmically understand this
by taking a variable the high kurtosis
knowing that the difference between your
outliers and your in lies are very very
high but you can't necessarily do that
in practice
because you're outliers don't
necessarily the outliers I'm not
necessarily definitely the things you
want to find they're just a medium to
find to find some of them basically so
with the variable searching you still
have to be very very yeah I still has to
be very very intuitive and you still
have to craft these variables which
obviously you're adding biased your in
and are kind of model here but there's
not really a foolproof way or if there
is I'd love to look to speak to anybody
who knows that foolproof way of doing so
you still have to kind of really really
manually craft these variables to make
sure that they are going to give you
give you actual cheaters rather than
just outliers so once we've got our
outliers what do we actually do with
them we actually kind of need a ground
truth so we work with you know and again
this is not there's no easy win here
unfortunately we have to go through a
sample of our data and just understand
what a cheater looks like versus a non
cheater we know that these outliers that
we found are most probably our cheaters
but there are going to be a lot of false
positives there there's going to be high
spenders and they're just going to be
people who are very very good at eye
game who have found kind of completely
legitimate ways through the problem with
that also is there's kind of a needle in
the haystack problem if we just sample
down our data and we've only got a 1%
outlier then there's only gonna be a few
people that are outliers so we're only
going to know a little bit about them
and we then will have a load of other
people that we don't see as outliers who
are probably not cheaters and we're not
going to see anything in between either
so if we look at the variables we're not
going to see like the tipping point in
which people are a cheater or in line
cheater so a really really simple way of
dealing with this is just resampling the
data based on the actual outlier score
the distance score or the error score
that we found from the neural net and
that means we get a really really good
representation across the board of
outliers in Liars and everything in
between and we can really really
understand the nuances and the tipping
points between who cheater and who's not
which is awesome and I mean it's a bit
of hard work it took me a few days of
just a lot of coffee going through a lot
of a lot of variables at this point but
we kind of had a labeled data set at
that point which we can kind of analyze
and model and we have kind of a
truth of who they're cheatin who aren't
so in terms of yeah just quickly so two
examples here of what we did actually
after it there's two games these are two
and Don Titans and me
they actually diverged in what we did it
after this so one of the games actually
after going through that process we
actually only found a finite amount of
ways that people were able to cheat the
game and so we kind of took a step back
um as I well we could obviously just
create classify here but given the fact
that our ground truth is only eight
facts about teachers we can in fact just
create very very simple heuristics on
those eight facts and and building a
model on top of those is is ridiculous
because you it's never going to be as
good as those eight facts that we found
for that ground truth so so we haven't
so in fact we just create very very
simple single Verity aristokraft that
data another game actually had much more
nuances and there wasn't much more
there's a lot of very very small ways
that people were cheating in such a way
that we weren't going to be able to just
craft a rule for each one of those so in
fact we actually just use that labeled
data set to build a classifier to
classify who is a cheater who wasn't and
that's kind of how we output that I'm
not going to kind of go into that cuz
this was more about kind of the outlet
out lie detection method but in practice
that's kind of what you end up doing
with your with your ground truth of data
once you've found those scores course so
barely so summary the fact is to find
and ban the cheaters there's obviously
issues with that our we're never going
to be able to just find cheaters because
actually all of our really really high
value players look exactly the same as
them so we were never going to be able
to do this in a simple way so there's
always going to be a lot of fun crafting
involved but we kind of used these out
lie detection methods to try and
pinpoint actual potential cheaters and
potential and high-value players such
that we can kind of we can understand
them better build models and build
infrastructure
so we can remove that players and kind
of let people enjoy the game that the
way they should and not feel like their
gain getting the short stick of the game
so kind of using into it intuitive
variables detecting the outliers kind of
either through very very simple
mechanisms or actually using kind of
neural nets to do so and then and then
there's all kind of like writing set
resampling that we use to to get a good
view of what an outlier looks like
versus not and then if everything in
between and that everything in between
it was the most important bit because we
really need to understand the tipping
points so and after that we kind of just
you know we've now got a ground truth in
it's just a it's just an exercise of
either building a classifier off it or
or creating new heuristics so yeah
that's kind of the journey that we took
through data fine using data science to
kind of take out find cheated in our
game has anybody got any questions
oh sorry note quickly knew that there's
one more and so just quickly you can
actually just find all of these stuff
really easy so cyclones got loads of
packages especially you're looking below
minimum covariance determinant and the
minimum volume ellipsoid there's a
implementation on github by Joanne's one
of our old analysts and the replicate in
your net doesn't currently have an open
source thing but if you're actually
thinking about the relaxed version of
what we'd built it's actually a very
very simple feed-forward neural net so
you can kind of build that either
through tend to flow on your own or
actually there's a very very simple
classify that they've built through
tensorflow to builder which is quite
good and so yeah questions
[Applause]
let's just say I get your game and I am
all right applause let's let your game
Judith but I'll only do it when we we
still miss a day of Thanksgiving today I
think it's on progress as much now which
is a look like and I've Eric's play it I
was a kid that's gonna make me possible
to do that it will but this is that a
necessary an issue I think I kind of
broached on it earlier on in the in the
presentation is actually if if we can't
necessarily detect you can i users
realize you're a cheater because that's
the only thing that we actually care
about we don't we don't generally who's
someone who's going to cheat in our game
is we're not gonna be able to slap them
on the hand and say don't cheat again
and they won't cheat again and they
might then spend in our game you know
it's not going to it doesn't do that so
we can either try and find absolutely
everybody or actually we just want to
focus on what is detrimental to our game
and the detrimental part is actually
just what what you can perceive is
cheating and that's the bit that one of
the biggest kind of points away from
this is actually like the perception of
cheating in the game over what's hit
over actually what cheaters are I think
that was one sorry
we do we do so the way that we actually
build the kind of end process is there's
not it's not completely we don't just
completely automate it there's certain
levels of it if we builds very very
simple heuristics of facts of like this
is a cheater we can kind of automate it
but there's a lot of levels of kind of
well there's a gray area here and it
goes to our support team to kind of make
a decision if people come back and we
are so that's so that kind of rules out
necessarily the kind of firm the false
positive of banning somebody but if they
come back we kind of have to just say
you're banned we can't tell them why
because they'll just learn how their
bands you know they'll learn the
constructs that we've put together to
stop them and so it's a case of just not
really talking to them this is it's kind
of just like I'm sorry you were banned
because we found that you would you were
cheating our game but we can't
necessarily tell them why because then
they'll just find new ways to do it
it's that similar arms race so what
we're trying to do is stop the arms race
by not telling them exactly not giving
them showing them everything so the
target variable is actually the data
itself so what we're trying to do is M
so what this neural net is doing it is
not trying to trying to predict whether
someone's a cheater on on we're just
taking our data so our three days say
for example our three data points that
we know if a user and we're running it
through a model such that we're
optimizing this neuron X such that this
this neural net can predict our input
data really really well so any normal
bit like so that's going to learn the
structure of the data any normal data
there'll be a very low error to it and
any outlier data which the neuro net
doesn't necessarily know is going to
then come out with a very very high
error rate and that's that's what we use
as a kind of an outlier factor
yeah it's kind of set yes so the
replicate the replicate in your net is
is the theoretical replicate in your net
is using the step function inside but
actually we've relaxed the assumptions
so effectively we're using an
autoencoder for a slightly different
purpose yeah there are so I mean the
first thing to think about is like hey I
mean we're talking my suspenders here
we've got a piece of data in the in the
fact that they've spent and so it's kind
of naively assumed that we could
probably just use that very very easily
but there's a lot of nuances in-between
for a fact that there's actually people
who decide to spend in our game and then
they go on to cheat and so we need to
kind of we can find ways in which we can
kind of separate them out but actually
we kind of have to treat them as similar
because they are similar behaving
players
our moral weight
and there is I can't I don't know
whether I can give that away so there's
certain things yeah
sorry but it's a good question there are
there are different ways that we can do
it and but I can't really go into it so
okay and I think right back you just
canvas replace a metadata attitude of
two ASIS or we'll have you might see
formulas each game as rules you might
political because all the excited just
heading some as a seller of like
associations or some yet on the South
Texas one both distances if you can
start testing is critical results as
numerical vary where variables how would
you think so that's so the first
question about the software engineering
problem so yeah you're right I think for
a lot of games you can deal with cheated
in that manner but the games that we
build are quite deep and level in kind
of complexity and actually we can most
of it is kind of authoritative in terms
if we can stop a lot of these things but
it's an incredibly deep problem and to
the point where you know there are
always going to be some ways in which
people can find ways around it and also
as I said it's an arms race there's
people that are legitimately like
spending days trying to find out how
they can don't get around our system and
I guess
you groom the step function of the pan
and the last yeah because you know
differentiation yeah and that space what
kind of magical process at some point
doing here that is true yes that is an
imagine that maybe the piece of rose
that is still to the clustering and then
also you get confirmations of clusters
and Ibiza and yes you're right and there
are that is definitely a way we could go
around it I don't think that was really
going to necessary solver problem here
though because in essence if we find
clusters in our data then they are a ABA
player behavior that is probably quite
normal
you know not everybody plays the game
exactly the same and so actually what
we're trying to find is the people that
don't fit into clusters about about data
that answer your question yeah so I was
thinking maybe the supposedly fosters
there was not in one of those clusters
that might be in red red single in the
same thing I guess you do yeah so now
you're catching and finally teachers how
does that Peyton so it companies
probably busy
and it's so the biggest thing is over
resource costs mainly and so for a while
we had a big team having to deal with a
lot of kind of you know a huge valley
manual process to do this and what we've
done is kind of found ways to completely
automate that and take that away from
them so it's a resource cost and also
it's just kind of consumer facing kind
of I think it you were saying is I was
the bottom line metric that we've
improved and the revenues there's
probably an implicit increase in revenue
given the fact that we if not the people
on perceiving cheated in our game
anymore and therefore not playing but
the one kind of metric that we were
trying to do is just kind of the amount
of complaints of cheaters that we're
having can we reduce that and we reduce
that by well fast amounts
but more like yeah yes so that's kind of
I didn't really go much into it I kind
of touched on it at the end is like once
we have that ground truth that's kind of
what we did but the problem being is
that right at the start is we don't have
that view and so we need ways in which
to be able to to filter through kind of
what could be a cheater what couldn't be
a cheater so that we can then go and
check and analyze that data yeah
so this is back to here so what we're
doing is using the outlier score to
resample the data such that we actually
have more yeah yeah yeah we have more
cheaters or more outliers in our data
that when we go and find the ground
truth will therefore have a larger
amount of things so it kind of deals
with that class imbalance it seems like
the issue is really I really use
experience fighting approval levels
really strong players telling you yeah I
used to be able to tell it in standing
or cheating and insider is not an
implicit thing that it spend us what's
really good for you and then that's the
game is a whole thing between billing
with you there's definitely there's
definitely in a slight issue at that
because because they look so similar
people can perceive cheating when
actually there's just people who are
very very active and I game and I'm kind
of high level so that's really that's
kind of a slightly different prom is
more like structurally how do we build
the game such that everyone can enjoy it
there's another point sorry what was the
other point to the question before you
yeah John's games not ruining user
experience and that was it the
identification so I mean that's
definitely an approach we can do we can
have a feature that kind of badges the
IPS but as a VIP do I want to know tell
people how much I've spent in this game
it's not necessarily like that's not
necessarily something that you'd
probably want to see be be showing as as
somebody who has kind of spent some
money in our game so it's yes it's a
very very tough one and that player
perception thing is a really a
completely different problem of you know
once we believe we've actually solved
the problem there's still that level of
somebody thinking that there's cheating
going on when actually they're just
seeing kind of very very active players
buying the game
colors already
so yes so you're saying so why do we why
do we not just have labels straight away
because we would we would end up having
users that we've already found before
this method that we know is cheaters the
problem is is we only have one label
that we don't have the the opposite to
it because then we just have a pool of
people that we think on cheating but
they could potentially be you know it's
one I think that it's it's similar to
the problem we had with the game in fact
that we didn't end up building a
classifier because we had ground truth
that we could attribute as these are the
exact ways that people are cheating and
so if we just tried to approximate and
build a classifier that approximated
those ground truths it would never be as
good as the ground truth itself but
there is that other and it also we're
kind of then also missing the extra
level of like the cheating we don't know
about and so that's why we kind of went
through this method of just fully
understanding the outliers and I game to
fully understand all of the different
practice of cheating
yeah that is still money I'm fortunate I
mean but it's worthwhile as well because
not because we've now taken a
statistical view of this now we need a
real like game view of why people are
doing this and we can and that's not
just affected cheating but it's affected
kind of how we built our game going
forward because we now understand not
just how to eat as a cheating but how
our kind of high level players are also
playing and what the differences are
yeah
and no and so it's it can be a problem
and it's definitely a problem amongst
these kind of deeper level games because
people people will spend a lot more and
definitely our social level it's a huge
problem because even if you have a small
amount of cheaters they can cause a lot
of negative feelings for all of the
legitimate players in your game but in
terms of so you know it's not
necessarily a fact of whether you've got
a high problem with teaching although
problem any problem with cheating is a
huge problem because it's in social
games it's going to affect this
legitimate place yeah for example that
people like spender are also tired or
that you want some broken and in the
previous episode zero was a typical way
to make sure
whereas how do you make sure that that's
a very good point and so you think how
can I just rephrase the question a
little bit are you saying how how did we
know the replication yarn that was
better than the distribution based
methods how do you make sure you some of
the concerns you have in the bracelet
which were that
okay so the first question on the kind
of replicate in your net is a it kind of
had there is no there's no one there's
no one way to do this it's not it's not
a very simple mechanism of just having a
value and making sure it's minimized for
the for the right model and what we
actually found is we actually used a
distribution based method on the first
on the first of our games that we did
this with um and that was implemented
but we learned a lot from it and
realized that there was certain areas
that we needed to address in in the way
that we calculated the outliers so when
we went to the you know net we kind of
made sure that it was as good as in
terms of the things that it was doing
well and it was actually taking care of
the problems that we've seen in them in
the in the first implementation so it
was a very very that's quite subjective
isn't it
it was it was kind of yeah it was it was
a relatively subjective approach what we
found is is it seemed to differentiate
true outliers a lot better but that yeah
generally it's quite subjective approach
and the second one was based on the
distributions so that again this was
kind of an implicit assumption but we
knew it would hold is there are very
very good at Ennead to be for the
distributions to work whereas actually
on on the net we knew that we wouldn't
have to worry as much of those at those
points but again it comes back to the
same thing we knew having implemented it
the problems that we'd found and the
reasoning because of some of our some of
our data wasn't actually we weren't able
to bring it into a kind of Gaussian you
know modal space we were then able to
check that once we implemented the
replicating on that that those problems
didn't no longer arrived
okay there's no more questions
[Applause]
[Music]